antonio guterres visitó turquía para
inspeccionar un barco listo para cargar
granos desde ucrania un viaje en el que
el secretario general de la onu evaluó
el avance del acuerdo que permite la
exportación de cereales desde dicho país
nordex sandra de más de 650 mil
toneladas métricas de cereales y otros
alimentos ya están en camino a los
mercados de todo el mundo
que operación tan notable e inspiradora
operation el nuevo buque sería el más
grande con 56 mil toneladas y es otro
paso para normalizar el flujo de
cereales a nivel mundial afectado por la
guerra en ucrania sin embargo todavía
tiene sus fisuras una de las principales
el acceso a los fertilizantes de ambos
países
sin fertilizantes en 2022 es posible que
no haya suficientes alimentos en 2023
sacar más alimentos y fertilizantes de
ucrania y rusia es fundamental para
tranquilizar los mercados y asegurar
precios más bajos para los consumidores
and low price is for canción merz
guterres anunció que está trabajando con
la unión europea y eeuu para asegurar la
salida de los fertilizantes claves para
contrarrestar la crisis alimentaria a
nivel mundial el 15 por ciento del
comercio mundial de fertilizantes a base
de nitrógeno sale de rusia al igual que
el 17 por ciento de los fertilizantes a
base de potasio según cifras del
instituto de investigación de políticas
alimentarias
a pesar de las trabas persistentes ya
son 27 los barcos que han salido de
ucrania con productos alimenticios una
operación que ha sido promovida por el
centro de coordinación conjunta que la
onu instaló en julio en estambul con el
objetivo de asegurar la salida de los
buques por el mar negro desde ucrania